[Musique]
et
bonjour industrielle de père en fils
depuis 1950
je représente la troisième génération
j'ai fait mes classes dans le d'abord
dans la société familiale industrielle
puis dans le syndicat des industriels
mon parcours
donc mon parcours aurait pu réellement
s'arrêter lorsque mon service militaire
en entreprise vie suspendue
mon père est tombé gravement malade et
il a été hospitalisé en france avant de
partir il m'a déléguer sa signature pour
une période de six mois en me laissant
pour seule consigne tu écoutes et
recense les problèmes auprès des
responsables et tu me rends compte
chaque soir et chaque soir je l'appelais
avec la preuve le problème m'en rappeler
et il me disait oui tu fais comme ça ou
non tu corriges et tu fais comme ça
c'est ainsi que me voilà toujours ici et
mon parcours
dans la société industrielle a d'abord
commencé comme magasinier en 2000 puis
agent commercial puis agent commercial
grands comptes puis directeur
d'exploitation
puis j'ai cumulé que directeur
commercial et directeur d'exploitation
puis directeur général adjoint et puis
directeur général depuis une dizaine
d'années dans le syndicat de l'industrie
autrement appelé l'organisation
patronale des industriels j'ai été
suppléant
je suis rentré comme supplément super
ans en 2004 j'ai effectué un premier
mandat comme vice président trésorier
j'ai fait puis j'ai effectué un second
mandat comme premier vice président puis
j'ai effectué un troisième mandat comme
président et je suis dans le quatrième
mandat en tant que président vous aurez
compris je suis donc doublement vissé à
l'industrie et j'en suis un fervent
défenseur
dans quelle situation se trouve
l'industrie malienne nous avons un
secteur secondaire
nous avons pardon un secteur
manufacturier où un secteur industriel
qui pèse 3 à 4% du produit intérieur
brut
cette situation nous a d'abord été du
point de vue macro peut remarquer et
c'est peut-être pour ça que nous avons
pris beaucoup de temps à en prendre
conscience
parce que quand on regarde le secteur
secondaire vous avez le bâtiment et
travaux publics
vous avez s'est terminée principalement
l'or au mali
et puis vous avez le secteur de la
manufacture vous synonyme l'industrie et
quand on prend le total de ces trois
vous avez dix huit et quatre vous avez 1
22% et la norme pour être un pays en
voie de développement et avoir un
secteur secondaire à gré ou tolérable et
donc entre 20 et 25%
fort de ce
de ce chiffre nous avons donc nous
n'avons pas été alertés probablement
attendre de cette situation de d'un
produit intérieur brut de la manufacture
trop bas deuxièmement il faut revenir
sur l'histoire de notre pays enfin de
notre industrie nous avons commencé par
une industrie public et nous avons
transféré l'industrie du public vers le
secteur privé d'en partir des années 80
il sauf que le transfert n'a pas été
fait sous une bonne forme
ça a plutôt été un abandon et cela nous
l'avons après encore davantage j'avais
renforcé lorsque nous sommes rentrés
dans le marché commun à partir des
années 2000 et donc que nous avons
intégré les réseaux offert le premier
réseau qui était celui de lui moi et là
vous allez c'est comme au sport quand
vous faites boxer un joueur de 50 kg
contre des joueurs de 100 kg ya pas
match donc du point de vue des règles
internationales d'arbitrage on avait un
match qui n'était pas qu'il n'était pas
fort équitable puis est arrivée la
montée en puissance progressive de la
concurrence déloyale et le développement
extraordinaire du secteur de l'informel
vous savez produire ces produits
importés c'est importé mais franchement
importés c'est beaucoup plus facile que
produire
je rappellerai un sage homme veut
mamadou bâ ancien président de l'ot pays
qui lors de l'assemblée générale de 2003
fini c'est ça son discours en disant
pour importer mille tonnes de sucre non
pardon pour produire 1000 tonnes de
sucre il faut près de 1000 personnes
mais pour importer mille tonnes de sucre
il faut deux personnes un trader mais un
magazine et
donc voilà la photo notre pays a connu
pour son secteur industriel une forte
désindustrialisation
quels ont été les les conséquences nous
sommes le premier pays importateur de
biens manufacturés
on est on est on est leader on a une
palme d'or dans la sous région on est le
premier pays importateur de biens
manufacturés ou de biens du court ça
fait de nous le premier importateur de
chômeurs nous avons une super casquette
nous sommes le premier importateur de
chômeurs et il y en a une deuxième c'est
que nous sommes des supers créateur
développeurs d'emplois chez nos voisins
principalement côtier alors j'adore la
mer mais franchement je préfère le
fleuve
donc j'aurai vraiment plaisir ac ce ne
soit pas cette première perspective là
qui en est résultée deuxième deuxième
phénomène marquant nous sommes le pays
des paradoxes industriels nous sommes le
premier producteur de coton d'afrique de
l'ouest
eh ben nous avons deux pour cent de ce
coton qui est transformé et encore quand
je quitte 2% la tendance est plutôt
baissière
nous sommes le premier cheptel d'afrique
de l'ouest
on en est fier eh bien nous sommes le
premier importateur de lait en poudre de
toute la sous région
avec ce beau cheptel également dont nous
sommes très fiers
nous sommes le premier exportateur de
viande sur pattes donc vous voyez nous
venons de perdre l'industrie laitière
l'industrie de la viande
l'industrie de la peau et l'industrie du
cuir lors troisième producteur d'or
d'afrique 1% de l'or et raffiné au mali
1%
autre paradoxe macro mais nous avons
deux fleuves magnifique et pourtant la
capacité de production énergétique est
les 200 mégawatts 250 mégawatts alors
que le besoin minimum aujourd'hui pour
le mali est de 500 mégawatts
je finirai par cette anecdote si ça peut
s'appeler d'anecdotes bamako notre
capitale est un champignon
nous comptons plus de 1000 immeuble
l'investissement pour faire un immeuble
et l'investissement pour faire une unité
industrielle significative est à peu
près le même faut compter à peu près le
même budget sauf que un immeuble vous
créer de l'emploi
uniquement au moment où vous gé cette
industrie c'est à ce moment là vous créé
l'immeuble eh ben c'est à ce moment là
pour créer cet emploi c'est le temps du
chantier
et ben non une industrie vous allez
créer vous allez avoir le même emploi au
moment de la création de cette industrie
mais après vous allez maintenir cet
emploi
tous les jours toutes les semaines tous
les mois tous les ans et sur une période
on souhaite un fini par conséquent et
ben je crois que j'ai mis l'industrie
que mills immeubles se manifeste
également par un chiffre que j'ai oublié
de citer nous avons une balance
commerciale déficitaire de 400 milliards
de francs cfa
le chiffre vaut la peine d'être appelé
et ce chiffre est permanent et récurrent
or je vais citer une autre citation
celle de abraham lincoln qui en 1900 en
1863 disait pour
lorsqu'on achète un bien à l'étranger
nash est un bien l étranger à l'argent
mais lorsqu'on achète un bien chez soi
on a le bien est l'argent donc ça
s'appelle le patriotisme économique
et c'est une valeur que j'aimerais que
l'on puisse y ont cultivé parce qu'elle
est elle est belle et on a vu où ça a
conduit les états unis donc sans
transition comment nous pourrions
inverser la tendance il faut il faudrait
faire travailler les usines et le parc
des usines industrielles malienne en
trois-huit là
la particularité de l'industrie c'est de
pouvoir travailler 24 heures sur 24
nous travaillons aujourd'hui
majoritairement en 1 8
donc c'est à dire un quart de 8 heures
au lieu de trois quarts qui font 24
heures sur 24
cette équation elle est permise elle est
possible pour ça il faut remplir le
carnet de commandes des industries et
pour ça il est souhaitable en effet
qu'ils puissent se lier se nouer un
partenariat intellectuel et
[Musique]
de solidarité de citoyenneté de façon à
ce que ce potentiel industriel puisse
être utilisé au maximum de sa capacité
c'est même chose si vous achetez une
voiture vous la gare et à la maison et
vous roulez jamais avec ces dommages
vous avez gaspillez vous avez cette
voiture utilisée au maximum de ses
potentialités fait la tournée au maximum
de ses potentialités
la deuxième chose très importante c'est
la commande publique
parce que oui pardon je reviens sur les
3,8
quand on travaille 24 heures sur 24 est
en trois huit
il ya un effet bénéfique que j'ai oublié
de siffler c'est celui de l'emploi mais
rien que sur ce potentiel là si au lieu
de travail en trois-huit ou travaux le
travail en 1/8 ou travailler en trois
huit mais manifestement 202 50000
emplois vous passer à 150 mille emplois
dont vous avez créé 100 mille emporte
donc juste la perspective de savoir que
nous pourrions augmenter l'emploi est
aussi un désavantage de
de faire tourner en trois-huit le parc
industriel ensuite je reviens à la
commande publique maintenant pardon donc
sur concernant la commande publique
elle est extraordinairement importante
elle un pouvoir d'entraînement
manifestent aujourd'hui si cette
commande publique pouvait être orientée
sur le made in mali
la commande publique pèse 600 milliards
de francs cfa par an le produit
intérieur brut de l'industrie nationale
malienne aujourd'hui je fais 300
milliards de francs cfa par an si vous
arriviez à récupérer que 50% de cette
commande publique sur le made in mali sa
doublerait le produit intérieur brut
national
donc on passerait manifestement d'une
population de 50 mille emplois à une
population de 100 mille emplois dans le
parc dans le parc industriel donc avec
les 100000 d'état leur en travaillant
3,8 les 50000 en récoltant une commande
publique
orienté vers le made in mali nous sommes
déjà à 150 mille emplois créés et je ne
parle pas de redémarrer le nombre
d'industries à l'arrêt qui sont évalués
à peu près à une centaine d'unités
industrielles qui ont fait faillite ces
dix dernières années qui sont là que
nous pourrions redémarrer troisième et
je m'arrêterai la solution orientée
l'aide des bailleurs de fonds vers le
vers le secteur industriel aujourd'hui
l'aide des ptf partenaires techniques et
financiers et s'est développée par
l'aide budgétaire directement vers le
ver l'état et l'aide projets directement
envoyés vers les ong
il faudrait créer une troisième
catégorie l'aide vers l'industrie je
n'ai mais je n'ai absolument rien contre
les ong elles sont géniales j'en suis
très fière et
et c'est très bien mais on nous sommes
très fiers d'être premier pays des ong
rapporté au nombre d'habitants
c'est très bien mais je préférerais que
nous soyons et on en dénombre 1000 je
préférerais que nous ayons 1000 unités
industrielles à milo nge et par
conséquent pour vraiment terminer mon
propos sur orienter l'aide budgétaire
vers le lait pts les partenaires vers
l'industrie j'opposerai au partenariat
public privé qu'on appelle communément
les 3 p la politique des 4p donc le
partenariat public-privé pts
l'avantagent de ce partenariat nouveau
futur
il serait de créer dans les vingt-cinq
filières prioritaires du développement
national donc elles sont connues ça va
de la mangue au karité en passant par le
cheptel l'élevage le coton les céréales
etc
mes prédécesseurs ont cité tout le
potentiel agricole et l'importance donc
si dans ces femmes 25 filières
prioritaires du développement national
nous pouvions créer ces fameuses
industrie locomotive en cas de paix nous
aurions l'état dedans pour la partie
civile représentant le foncier nous
aurions le privé dedans pour la partie
management gouvernance et les réalités
et nous aurions les ptf pour la partie
structuration assistance technique
financement après vous me répondrez mais
les ptf ont pour vocation de faire des
projets de trois ans
normalement ces trois ans trois ans
éventuellement renouvelable de trois
fois et bien là on leur fixerai comme
deadline de rester au maximum 10 ans et
de sortir par la bourse régionale des
valeurs mobilières d'abidjan
parce que aucune industrie malienne ne
figurent encore sur la cote de la bourse
régionale mobilières des valeurs de
l'allusion voilà si vous nous si on
devrait retenir qu'une seule chose de de
mon propos qu'une seule chose
l'industrie est un médicament c'est un
médicament contre la pauvreté le chômage
et le retard économique augmenter le
pourcentage du pib de l'industrie c'est
se soigner c'est se faire du bien c'est
guérir quand vous allez aller sur
internet et que vous allez consulter
monsieur google au madame wikipédiens
taper un pays développé et vous verrez
la réponse un pays industrialisés merci
[Applaudissements]